I am very, very sad recently.
Electoral vote is going on...
According to current trends, Donald J. Trump is expected to become the next US president
Recently, I have been examining my life and wondering what I should do to make my life better.
Is the largest pizza in your store a few inches?
Is that the only thing?
Ok
Then I will order a 20 inch.
I have been experimenting with a variety of different things over the past year.
I want to know if there will be any surprises in doing this.
Fortunately, I found a lot of things that made me very happy.
I carefully analyzed the reasons and realized all these different things.
Can be summarized in one word, a very simple word:
growing up
When I grew up, it was my happiest moment.
Whether learning a new skill, reading,
Try to challenge your inner fears and participate in charity events
Travel, feel different cultures, exercise, and receive treatment
Make your heart stronger
These have calmed my heart and kept growing.
When you start thinking about it, it works. Is it not?
I mean, we are all humans, not only do our bodies need to exercise
Our mind also needs to grow
When we refuse to progress, refuse to learn, and refuse to challenge, the feeling of stopping will make you uncomfortable.
Baby, how are you doing today?
You asked me the same question at the same time yesterday.
Pay tribute to President Trump
So if you really feel unhappy, I hope you can find a way to grow.
What traps you tightly? Is it intelligence, body, mind, spirit, or emotion?
What can you do to improve yourself in all aspects and become the one you want to be?
Deepen your friends' feelings? Going to the Lyra hoop class?
Do you adopt as many cats as you can within your country or state?
No matter what, what you need to do is to keep growing, you will become happier, I promise
I am Anna akana, keep curious.
Hey, don't go, tell you, I recently worked with Crowdmade.
They are great, if you don't know them yet, go get to know.
Especially Corridor Merch, I am his super big fan.
I designed a pattern of happy cat bottles.
Is a limited sale, only 15 days of the scheduled period, snapped up, or there will be no 喔~
Go to Crowdmade.com/AnnaAkana and get your happy cup.
Click on the video link
Already mentioned at the end, cool
Cool, bye, go buy it.